Let’s turn to key conflicts. Remember we talked
about two different ways to assign a key.
The first where datastore automatically assigns a key
value for you. And the second was you can
provide a key name ID that generates the key. And when you provide a keyname ID,
you're responsible for ensuring that they are unique
for all entities of that kind. This is important,
because otherwise you will generate a key conflict. That's
right, we do not want to cause a datastore key
conflict. That's for sure. Let's see what they are
and how we can avoid them. Let's go back to
recipes for a moment. Say, for example, that we
have the recipe kind that we worked with before. And
we want to insert a vegetarian lasagna entity and a
meat lasagna entity into the datastore. Well, if I let
datastore generate the keys then it will make sure
to create two unique keys. One for the vegetarian
lasagna entity. And one for the meat lasagna entity.
So two unique keys. But let's say that I
instead want to generate a key from a keyname
ID that I specify. Then it is very important
that I can guarantee that those are unique. In
this example, it is very bad to choose lasagna
as a keyname ID if both vegetarian lasagna
and meat lasagna would have lasagna as the
key name. The reason is that when you
insert the first entity, it will get it's key
based on the key name ID lasagna. But when you later insert the meat lasagna, it
will override the vegetarian lasagna, because it also
has the key name/ID lasagna. So again, remember this,
when you are explicitly setting a key name ID.
You have to ensure that they will be unique and
in our application, it is safe to use user
ID, because the uniqueness of it is ensured by the
user authentication system. As it turns out, this is
actually quite convenient since it makes it easy to retrieve
the profile from the data store. That's exactly the
code we will add in the coming exercise. Have fun.